Hey, what's going on?
It's Bill Burr and it's time for the Monday morning podcast for Monday,
January 3rd, 2017. What's going on how are
Yeah.
How's it going? Oh, Jesus. What to talk about first?
Uh, no, I am not a father. That's not why this is fucking late. All right.
And I just lost all my female female listeners.
I was at the rose bowl yesterday. That's why I did not record. Okay.
I watched a bunch of college football this weekend.
[inaudible]
right? I watched a bunch of, um,
a bunch of college football got into this huge debate with Jason [inaudible]
heard before the Ohio state game going, dude,
I still don't get how the fuck you guys are in the playoff.
And Penn state isn't, you know, you guys lost to Penn State,
head to head and Penn State one year conference championship.
That would be like if that the Yankees won the American league east and the Red
Sox won the wildcard and then the red sox got to compete in the playoffs to
possibly win a world series. And then the Yankees didn't,
that makes no fucking sense whatsoever. And he starts going, well,
I'll tell you where I know we had a, we had three,
the most impressive road wins of any team, blah, blah, blah,
just all of this shit. And I just kept going, you bleed scarlet and gray.
If this was happening to your team, you would say it was bullshit. And he said,
no, I wouldn't. I be asking why a Washington,
The Washington huskies were in it like he would have no problem with the team
that his team beat. And when the fucking camera give me a fucking break. Right.
And then what happens? What happens?
Ohio state goes out and plays Clemson and they go out and proceed to get their
asses by a bunch of Goddamn nerds.
It's 31 to nothing.
Clemson just fucking completely dominated them.
And in the end ly had sends me this fucking text. He said,
I can see Blahblahblahblahblah.
And then I just sent him a picture of Joe Paternal shrugging and said,
I didn't see nothing.
Maybe that's what part of it is.
Maybe that's why they still don't want Penn state to be in there. You know?
Cause at the end of the fucking day, the end of the day,
this guy kind of fucking, you know,
it was a lot of shit going on in the shower there when the guy,
he fucking didn't say nothing. It was so weird about being at the game.
Cause I was rooting for Penn state yesterday at the amazing,
amazing fucking game by both teams. The quarterbacks,
the both set like tight or set up zillion fucking records as the highest scoring
rose bowl in history. Uh,
at one point both quarterbacks had four touchdown passes, which I don't think,
I think that tied of record or I can't remember. And then one, the, uh,
the red headed kid there threw his fifth,
I think he was ran and I was fucking sitting way up there. Um,
he threw his fifth touchdown. So a final score was, what was it,
52 to nine. The over under was 53 and a half.
So, um,
Penn State scored 28 points in the third quarter.
It was just a fucking amazing game. And, uh,
two things bug me when I watched when I was there though. Of course,
there's always something that bugs me. Okay. Number one, the fucking,
uh, at one point they was showing all,
like the coaches were one of the Roosevelt, whatever.
And Joe Paterno goes up there and this is,
he gets a bigger elevation than anybody else.
Bigger ovation than anybody else. How important are sports?
How important is fucking winning of fucking game?
Do these Penn state people evidentaly that's more important than if you look the
other way is some poor kid in a fucking shot mean it's just fucking, it's,
it's unspeakable. All right. I, I just fucking,
I'm stepping away from that fucking program. I've always liked him. You know,
I was still kinda rooting for him. I was like, well, you know,
these kids here on the field day didn't fucking do it. These other people are a,
they're in a sin of all of it. And then they show, you know,
they show the fearer up on the fucking, yeah,
I'm just saying I fuck these people. Right.
But then USC and their fans, you know,
USC fans are the, uh, the classic, you know,
all day yellow dashes. You know what I mean? Yeah.
There's just so fucking hard to root for it despite the fact, you know, um, oh,
J Marcus Allen o j pre murders.
Like if they put OJ up on the screen, you know, I wouldn't have fucking show.
I probably would've just to be a cunt. All right. I'm a Penn state fan again.
I don't want the, I don't want, what are you doing that situation anyways? Um,
so Penn state, uh, U s USC, it looks looking like they get a win the game. Okay.
And then Penn state comes roaring back in the third quarter, which by the way,
took like an hour in like 10 minutes. It was the longest quarter of my life.
The TV timeouts were fucking ridiculous in that game.
I actually said to my buddy, I was just like, dude, you know what?
This is the most boring, exciting game I've ever been to in my life.
It was like every,
it was like if you were watching good fellows and it'd be fucking three seconds.
Somebody just hit pause on it for two minutes.
That felt like 10 minutes fucking referee standing around.
They fucking reviewed everything. Everything went the fucking coin toss.
They reviewed that, that that game was like four hours,
well over four hours long. So anyways, Penn state comes roaring back.
Fucking USC fans, few of them left. Most of them stayed and a, anyways,
long story short, they end up coming, you know that they were down by like a,
I can't remember like 27 14
the next thing you know it's 35 27
yeah.
Then I think it was (353) 053-0520 seven Penn state than 35 35 then 42 whatever.
35 then 49 35 and that's right. Then Penn state,
I mean USC came back and scored two touchdowns. Right. And when they tied it,
the fucking UFC USC players, just the way they act,
their program is the fucking worst. They're the F that's the like that,
the type of a program.
I can't stand like you remember the first game of the year when they played
Alabama and when they were coming out of the tunnel,
there's a bunch of them acting like they were these craze dogs at the end.
Alecia's and they were luncheon forward. Somebody pulling her back. Oh,
you guys all, you wait to see what the fuck's going to happen here.
And then they go out there and proceed to get their asses.
But once you God damn rednecks red fucking like Alabama kicked the shit.
It was like 52 to go fuck yourself, whatever the final scores.
And then after all that fucking shit, then they just come out and hey,
good game, good game. Well they just scurry off the fucking field. Right?
And then yesterday you see when they win, right? They win like first of all,
when they, they, they tied the game up,
you know. And I would say on some ticky tack fucking, uh,
pass interference calls.
But like USC was getting fucking screwed earlier.
They had a couple bullshit. It was just sort of odd.
We fucked you guys twice and then, uh, we'll, we'll,
we'll fuck the other guys twice. Okay, well balance it out here somehow. Um,
a couple pass interference thing.
So when they scored the touchdown to tie it up with like a fucking minute left
or something, dude, all the scoring that Penn state did,
I mean they jumped up and down. That was a two fucking USC.
The guy they scored in one end zone. This guy with no helmet on,
runs down the sideline to the entire other end zone. Like,
ah, doing that 300 yells like he fucking scored.
Even then I would've been like, dude, relax.
It's a fucking tie game all jumping up and down,
all up on the benches with their fucking Jersey,
spinning them around over their fucking heads and it's a tie fucking game.
And then in the end, right by the way, Penn state totally played fucking
Marty Schottenheimer Bald Marty Ball. I swear to God.
Like every time they had a first down towards the end,
they just written the first play was running right up the middle. Right?
Nia Center's fucking ass for no gun, no yards.
Well there were burning out the where we're, you know,
we're taking time off the clock. They were doing that shit. I said,
I'm actually still,
I'm convinced that the prevent defense by the way is actually a,
it's a scam that was come up with by the heads of the leagues that is executed
by the coaches to make sure every fuck as many games as humanly possible can
come down to the wire so people will continue to watch that fucking thing.
Once again, did not work. I can't even begin to tell you that.
Just you just going to give them the first fucking 80 yards.
Then you're going to play defense and hope that you hold them to a field goal.
That's a philosophy and they will just, we'll take away the sidelines,
the middle of the field, everybody knows how it fucking works in.
All it does is ensure that on the final fucking three four plays,
the other team now has a chance to win. You've been playing defense,
you've been shutting them down. You've been throwing the fucking ball.
You've been kicking their ass and then all of a sudden hand up up the middle
every fucking time. I Dunno. Drove me up the fucking wall.
So then when USC finally wins it right after letting up 49 fucking points and
then they score 52 the second day when at the entire team runs down the field,
not towards the field. KIP, go kicker to celebrate.
Who by the way was doing that stupid dap thing, the entire fucking thing,
trying to get like a sneaker deal.
It's like what kind of kicker gets a sneaker deal? They get like half a deal.
They just get it for their kicking foot. Then the other thing,
they give them like a fucking Sandal,
so they don't even go out and celebrate with the fucking kid who kicked the
field goal.
They just run right down at Penn state's band and the whole fan section and just
screamed all in their faces.
And what's fucking hilarious is that game obviously could've gone either way and
if they didn't win, they would've been like, oh hey, good game.
[inaudible] Penn state wouldn't have done that.
But just a completely classless fucking move. But that's how they are, you know,
that's one of those schools will say, well,
the coach just doesn't take any responsibility. It was just like, well, uh,
the kids are this, uh,
it's very emotional team and they like to express themselves and have that,
yeah. Yeah. When they, when, when they, when, when they don't,
they fucking scamper off the field.
It's like that Richard Sherman guy, whenever the Seattle Woods you met,
you met Bro, you met, right. And then all of a sudden he loses,
he tries to be Mr [inaudible]. He tries to be the mayor. Hey,
good game Tom Brady. Good game. Everybody's like that showed class. No,
it didn't. Anybody can be classy when you fucking lose, you can't talk shit.
You lost the class.
Act is when you win and you're not account about it. Um,
but anyways, having said that, it was a fucking amazing, amazing game.
Great comeback by a USC. And uh,
is as much as it came down to the wire and there was all those points scored.
I have to be honest with you, I,
if I could have fast forwarded through the last 45 minutes of the fuck,
that's how long the fucking game was and how long these fucking TV timeouts were
. I can't imagine how much fucking money they made. The game started at one 15.
It wasn't over until like, uh, I have, I want to say like five 45,
five 40. It was just way too far. It was over four hours long.
It was like a fucking baseball game. It's like this is,
this is what I am to the national pastime. Bill.
You know what was almost as long as you bitching about the fucking game. Um,
anyways, so we went to the tailgate and um, I brought that,
uh, that flat top grill that I got the campfire one. Um,
this is not a paid advertisement. Dude. Fucking thing was unbelievable.
It was un-fucking-believable la head was I, I had,
didn't want to go to the game. He was having so much fun.
He cooked so much shit. I make, we had so much fucking food,
we had too much food and it's,
that's why I felt like I got hit by a truck cause I ate so fucking much. And um,
I made these hash browns, he made this crazy egg sandwich.
Then we had chicken wings,
then we had fucking steak and cheese and we still had burgers and dogs that
we're gonna try to do at the end of the game. But I was just too fucking full.
But a law head was fucking hilarious man. He was so excited to cook.
Right.
I'm back in the truck and he's outside of it and this guy comes walking by and
you know when they, they sell those ticket holders, I always get one right.
And he goes, I hey ticket. Oh you took it? I go, yeah, yeah, let me get four.
So these guys sort of walking up to the truck and I'm not doing a good job back
in it in, because the grills block in my view, I'm trying to look around.
I don't want to fuck this thing up in a, so I had to do,
can you make a couple of attempts and rather than blaming it on me,
chase starts yelling at the ticket guy cause hey buddy, hey think he get up,
get out of the way. Let the kid fucking party. And they,
I didn't see the guy going, hey bro, you got, you got to relax.
And Jay just starts fucking John at him.
Like he's fucking arguing when a call and I just yelled out.
I just automatically said, Jamie, just shut the fuck up. I got to what?
I'm sorry. Sorry about that guy. You know, he's, he's little wound up, right? So
we had fucking buy the ticket, hold that things,
the guy leaves and then Jay set up his fucking,
his little canopy thing and he's just fucking, he's just locked in,
you know, Jay's a fucking athlete so he just fucking gets, he's,
he's got that focus, right. And as he set the thing up, like these four people,
we've barely even establish our space or just passing through.
And then Jay immediately they just walked in the whole area.
Like freaking the fuck out. I said to him later, I said, Jesus Christ,
Jay, I go,
you fucking dropped the gloves before the game even started with the fuckers
with you. And he's like, no, not at guys. The guys walking, right. And he tires,
what can you tire people come through the whole fucking camp.
And I just started laughing. I was like, Jay, you're excited to cook.
Say the cookie.
You get a little excited that he finally just fucking just relax and goes all
right. He got excited. Um,
I don't know. We are, we are on a weird are just weird. A great fucking time.
And um, I dunno, I still nodded off a little bit in the first quarter.
You know, I can't get to sleep after all these years of doing,
stand up till like fucking 12 midnight and get up,
you know, four hours later. I'm an old fam. I really felt my age this year, man.
Uh, speaking of which, there was someone at the Tailgate, I'm not gonna say who,
who was fucking slumped over the truck cause they had to go the bathroom and
couldn't. So we're like, dude, we got to take you to the hospital.
We've gotta take your ass. Naw, I'm fine. I'm fine. I'm fine. Fuck you.
Ends up coming back like 20 minutes later, dude. And I feel great because I eat,
I think he passed a fucking kidney stone or subs.
I don't know what the fuck it was.
I don't know what to tell you. Ah, yeah.
So we almost had a fatality lion almost got a gay misconduct.
No, that was the bullshit one on USC. That fucking, uh,
targeting that was that, that was a, I don't know. Guy Jumps in the air.
He's aiming for his chest and somebody else hits them.
Then all of a sudden the guy gets knocked down. Where is his chest?
His head is now where his chest wasn't and the guy was already in the air.
Right. Does anybody give a fuck? Alright, I'll, I will plow.
I will plow ahead here. Um, I also watched the UFC.
I know this is like an old story at this point, but, um, you know,
everybody, like everybody else, I watched the, uh, Amanda Nunez and
the Ronda Rousey Rowdy Ronda Rousey fight and uh, yeah, that was tough to watch.
That was definitely tough to watch and um,
it was even tougher to watch all the fucking shit talk and assholes on like
Twitter and all the means. Yeah,
no, really fucking, uh, you know, I've taken nap plug in the net.
They went to get a drink and then it was fucking off.
It's just like, like all of these people that have,
have fought and competed in one in the octagon and they have the right to talk
shit like that. It's just a, I don't know why people do stuff like that. Uh,
you know, that happens to every champion if they, if they stay,
if they stick around eventually somebody younger is going to see you're the
champ.
Everybody's breaking down what the fuck it is you do over and over and over and
over again. And then eventually you get run down. It happens to everybody.
If it could happen to Mohammad Ali, sugar ray, Leonard, Marvin,
Hagler, all these fucking guys, their last fight, I saw him loose.
Roy Jones Jr Matt Hughes, George Saint Pierre, right.
I think George Saint Pierre might've won his last one,
but he was all beat up and everything. But um,
and said he didn't remember part of the fight.
So that's what happened to everybody. So of course I texted it to my buddy,
he goes, well, not rocky or fucking Mayweather,
meaning rocky Marciano and it's just like, dude, alright I'll,
I'll rocky Marciano. Absolutely. But like Mayweather, I dunno.
Mayweather owes me like 300 bucks in paper view.
Thinking about that guy. All right,
I'm really going out on a limb here cause I don't watch that much boxing.
I think one, obviously one of the greatest fighters of all fucking time,
but like he's just also understood that final third of his career,
I feel better than anybody else.
How do you still continue fighting and not take that big fucking knocked down?
Part of it or a lot of part was his amazing defense,
but the other is the fucking opponents that he picked. You know what I mean?
That fucking Pacquiao fight should have happened at least eight years before I
was on his side where I was like, yeah, maybe he's on drugs. He probably,
I don't know, maybe is, maybe fucking isn't, but, um,
I don't know all the, I don't know. Boxing isn't the way it was. Um,
somewhere in the 80s that died like [inaudible]
okay.
That Hagler Hearns Duran Leonard,
they all lost and they all fucking lost to each other and shit. It's just like,
he had unbelievable fighters for unbelievable fighters and they all fought each
other. It's impossible to stay undefeated, but, um, you know,
when you fucking, you know, it'd be like a fucking Ali fought,
you finally fought Joe Frazier in like 1981.
And like when Ali's last fight, I think it was against Larry Holmes,
who then was the fucking champ for like the next four years or whatever his rule
until I think Tyson came along and maybe there's one guy in between,
I can't remember. It's been so long ago.
Hagler's last loss was to sugar ray Leonard.
I mean these guys fought champions right up until the end of their career as
opposed to a, you know, fighting some guy from England with weight issues.
You know that one Ricky, Ricky, uh, Ricky Hatton. I saw that fight.
I don't like talking shit about fighters either because you know, they,
they cannot beat the fuck out of me. I'm, I'm just saying that, you know,
I think it's gonna hurt Mayweather,
the level of guy that he fought in the final third of his career.
Um, cause I know for one, like I just, you know, you'd watch his fucking fights.
The other guy couldn't hit him.
Mayweather could knock him out and he just kind of poo poo, poo,
poo poo the whole fucking fight with this, those white kitten gloves.
I'm just like, this is fucking boring. The Shit
I'm fighting not to lose play and not play,
not to lose like Penn state like Penn state did in the fourth fucking quarter.
Um, so that's, I know, that's my own dumb opinion. I don't know what,
I don't know shit about fighting,
but all I know this is you're a fucking asshole if you go on Twitter and you
start trashing somebody cause they, uh,
cause they got knocked out like they're a pussy or you,
you are overrated or any of that type of shit. I mean, some, you probably say,
I just did that to Mayweather. I'm not,
I'm saying he's one of the greatest of all time.
I would never say that the guy's a pussy or anything like that.
I would've just liked to watch him fight, uh, better caliber fighter.
Um, I dunno. You know what I mean? I like that.
That may weather pack your fight.
That should have fucking happened in one oh five oh six something like that.
Bill. Shut the fuck up. All right. I'll shut the fuck up anyways. Um,
you know what? It really is his adverse,
he fucking said that Mayweather would've fucking beat Hagler Hearns Leonard
Duran, like he would've fucking beat all of them.
It's like he would've beat all of them.
All of them couldn't beat all of each other. You know, I dunno what he's,
I don't know what he's basing it on. You know what he's basing it on?
He's basing it on being born in the late seventies. I just, you know,
I'm just an old fucking crabby men, I'm speaking of which, you know,
I've, I've been working on my anger. Um,
I got in the car today to return the pickup truck and I, uh,
okay.
I fucking, uh, I don't know.
I made it down the street around the block before I got into an argument with
this fucking woman who just glided through her stop sign in her white
Mercedes-Benz. I gotta fucking, I got it. Anybody who's got a white Mercedes,
a white, uh, people, white cars, men,
high end white cars are fucking entitled cunts.
I don't like, you know what I mean? They think the car is a classy right.
I was [inaudible] shit like verse, he loves a white car,
you know, it just,
it gets the classiest fucking thing ever.
Mercedes and BMW, they've really fallen the fuck off. You know what I mean?
They just went right down to the bottom feeders.
Anybody with like sue can afford 60 bucks a month, can lease one of those cars.
Now I'm telling you, when he used to see a Mercedes drive down the street,
used to be some fucking guy like in his 50s,
who was wealthy or have a BMW.
Even then that was like a more like the Yuppie guy. Like,
I'm not having fucking kids and I'll pour shit in the drinking water just to
make another buck, you know, Cook the fucking stock market banker's psycho,
right? We would just have it rough sex, you know, that fucking lunatic.
Um, now it's shit. It's like, it's like fucking 21 year old kids.
Um, I think this podcast should just be like a, some sort of theme of like,
things aren't the way they used to be and I'm fucking upset about it. Um,
you know what it is, is I didn't have a good breakfast today and at my age,
that's not a good thing. You know, I woke up in the,
and we didn't have any fucking real food to fucking my,
my frying pan was underneath all these dirty shit from the fucking rose bowl.
That's in the sink. It's like, I'm not going to fry up a fucking egg.
And a Nia has one of those fucking little kids cereals in there.
And I was just like, all right, I'll fucking eat this shit. And uh, um,
I already had the fucking sugar high and now I'm starting to crash.
So I'm being, uh, being a little harsh on the millennials, you know,
in Floyd Mayweather and people who drive white cars.
I can admit that in 2017,
I can admit that this is the new me, the new bill.
I meditate now and by saying I meditate means I tried it once last week
and I plan on doing it twice a day, but I've only done it once so far, but,
but I've been thinking about doing it, you know, and uh,
people have been sending me shit about trying to get over my fucking anger
issues and uh, yeah,
that lady like glided through the stop sign and I just, I stopped, I said,
you gotta Stop Sign, right? Then she goes, you got one over there. And I go,
that's not it. It's the other one. It's just like,
you just don't fucking nother Douche in a white Mercedes. I swear to God.
Do you think if they stopped making that car, people would drive better?
If there's something about people and then they get in a white Mercedes,
a white fucking car, like, you know of up, that costs a certain amount of money.
That's it. Look, I'm good. I'm getting upset again. Just relax bill.
Take a fucking breath. You know, go outside. Look at the birds.
Where the hell it is you supposed to do? You know somebody sent me this. I get,
I should play it now. Somebody sent me this fucking video on a,
you know how to get over my anger and uh,
at the risk of sounding like a heck comedian, it actually,
it didn't make me angry. It fucking upset me though. It really didn't.
Let me see this here. See if I can click on this fucking thing again. Oh,
how not to be angry all the time.
I wonder if I can play this and not get in fucking trouble by some, uh,
some podcasting entity here. See if I can turn this fucking thing up here.
So I, I look at this thing, right? It's a cartoon.
So immediately it's on my intellect level. Right? Here it is. This,
this is what they're trying to say to me. I'll try to play this year,
my minimal fucking um, abilities here.
Oh, for God's sake. So you're gonna play it here or what?
I hit play.
Okay.
I refuse to get fucking angry during this point. Why won't this thing play?
Yeah. Oh I know. Cause I'm in this room. I'm in this room.
So the fucking in the internet doesn't work all, there's a little spin wheel.
It's gradually fight spinning around. What's going to happen?
All I want to do is play this fucking all. I wanna do room a zoom, zoom, zoom.
I just want to play this fucking video. How does it know?
How does the universe know when you're trying to fucking do something?
All right. You know what? Fucking, I'm not playing. Hey look at that.
I'm not angry anymore cause I just gave in because that's basically what this
fucking video told you to do. It was talking about so and so.
This is the name of the video. It says how not to be angry all the time.
And I would love to read the fucking comments on this thing, right?
This is how not to be angry all the time. And it shows this guy,
it's like a William or whatever. I think you guys actually name was bill.
I can't remember. He, you know,
he likes to read the newspaper and he tells his wife not to interrupt him while
he's doing that. And then it goes, his wife finds it's very upsetting.
So one time he's reading the newspaper and uh, she says, Hey,
when are you going to, uh, you know, set the table but blah, blah, blah, blah,
blah. And William flips out,
he gets angry and it says William gets angry because he has hope.
It was talking about how angry people, as much as they come off as a negative,
directly, really positive people. It was basically saying that they have hope.
So they present all these different scenarios and they're like,
at each one of these cell, you know,
he goes to the airport and his plane is delayed.
He's one of the premier fucking flyers. He gets mad, he goes up, he flips,
he screams at the fucking lady behind the counter because he is hopeful and it
was basically saying that he needed to be a little more pessimistic. Oh,
here's the video. Here's the video.
It's basically saying you needed to be a negative cut.
Here we go like gloomy times.
We certainly don't usually think of them as a whole.
Why is it so fucking quiet?
Gruff snafus? They treat me much to their constitute.
You know what? I can't deal with this fucking guy's accent.
I can't deal with it. Oh, I know. I had them.
I had the fucking microphone turned round. There we go.
Do you meet people the Actually, Oh,
hold on one sec.
And Green. People sound like [inaudible] meet times.
We certainly don't usually think of the past optimists and yet gruff surface.
They truly are much to them.
I can't fucking, oh my God, I can't fucking listen to it.
Okay.
Kenny, when is he going to fuck it over it? And that's everything.
And Nancy had everything gloomy papal deck actually potted the people under
that. Um, yeah. So basically he goes through all of this fucking shit, right.
And he says in,
in to be more positive is what you have to do is you have to accept the world
that the world is actually a very dark gluey place and most things fail and most
basically, most dreams don't come true. And uh, you know,
be more of like a realist in like people who, you know, people get upset,
people who aren't angry, people get upset, um,
when something happens,
but they get over it way quicker and they don't get nearly as mad.
And it's basically because I guess they're walking around going like, oh yeah,
why wouldn't this person in this white Mercedes blow through the stop sign?
Of course they do.
I guess there's part of me that I understand that like I flip out about the more
on drivers out here and I literally say to myself out loud after I flip out in
the car going like, yes, Bill,
you have established that people out here suck at driving.
When are you going to stop reacting to it? And um, you know,
I, I don't think ever,
I don't think it's because I'm like an optimist. I don't have,
I'm not hopeful that someone fucking,
you know, if they're going to make a left, that they,
that they'll get all the way over to the left instead of sitting in the middle
of the lane and now I have to fucking wait where if you just were over by the
double yellow line, I could have gone around you. You fucking cunt.
I'm not like hopeful that they're going to do that.
I don't have like hope that they're going to do it.
I just can't understand why you wouldn't because I know that person has been
sitting behind somebody doing that. It's like when you're,
you're in a long line and fucking whatever and it's moving slow and everybody's
yammering what the person on the other side of the fucking desk, it's like,
just get up there and say what you want and shut the fuck up. How hard is that?
And there'll be a person in front of you look at you rolling their eyes. Like,
I can't believe how long this takes.
And then they get up there and what are they done today?
It's a great day out there.
They just fucking launch into all of this shit that has nothing to do with what
you're doing.
Yeah.
And it just fucking adds time.
So I'm not, I don't have any hope that people are gonna
okay.
Maybe I do. I have hope. You know?
I guess I would hope you'd be a fucking not a moron and figure out why this
seems to be taking way longer than it should. I Dunno.
I don't think it's because I have hope.
I think the reason why I get fucking angry is because that is my default
emotion. I think that that's what it is. You know,
I came from one of those families, oh my God, shut the fuck up.
You sit there and take it, right. One of those things, which, you know,
if you're not allowed to express yourself,
you immediately feel like you're not going to get what you want in life.
And I think that that's what is, I think that's why I flip up. You know,
I flip up because of that. Like, you know, if something starts to go away,
I don't want it to go, um,
no one's going to listen to me and I don't have any fucking options other than
just sit there and fucking take it. So I think that's what he's,
I don't think it's, cause I'm hopeful. I get maybe a little bit,
maybe I'm such an angry cunt. I can't say that there's some truth in this video,
but I don't think the solution is, is to just walk around. Um,
yeah.
You know, just accepting that people are the way that they are,
you know, that'd be like, if you know, you're coaching a team, it'd be like,
yeah, you know, we're eight and eight. Yeah, we're just eight and eight. Yeah,
next year. Yeah. I will probably be eight and eight again because a, I've,
I've accepted that this is the way things are. Um,
I know a lot of positive driven people and they're not angry people.
So I don't think being positive as part of that. I think it's,
I think it's just how my fucking wires,
my mental wires have been soldered together.
I think I probably came into the world, I dunno.
Can you come into the world angry?
Okay.
I Dunno. I don't think he can. I don't think you're born that fucking way.
I have no fucking idea, but I don't,
I dunno about this video where I got to now just, I just,
the solution is just to be like, yeah, well you know,
people out here when they make lives, that's how they're going to do it. I mean,
I guess if you just do that, then you don't get angry.
Cause all these years in me getting angry has not made people stop doing that.
It never made the person in front of me go like, oh I'm sorry, let me get over.
They just sort of look at me weird as I, as I drive by yelling at them,
looking at me like, what the fuck is he yelling at me?
Am I doing something I have no, I have a white car.
How could I possibly be in the wrong? Um,
I dunno. I have no idea. I think a,
I dunno, I don't know what my deal is,
but I plan on getting to the bottom but at least understand it.
But I don't think a three minute fucking youtube video with some guy with his
fucking, you know,
I think in the United States we like getting like people with English accents to
fucking narrate shit cause that it just sounds like it's true. Are Smart,
you know what I mean? Which is why I think all these, uh,
these English guys have been Scottish guys have done wealth. Um,
maybe it's just women like fucking that accent or just like a different foreign
accent. I don't know, like these talk show people, you know,
for some reason that slot that used to be after David Letterman,
you have to get an English or a Scottish guy. Like,
that's become like that time slot, like an American accent.
That guy can not do well in that.
That is the Great Britain accent time slot.
Um, I dunno, I, I, but I, I all I know is, I can't,
I can't listen to fucking, I can't listen to this again. He's a friend.
He's furious. He's been married to is,
he's often furious. He sounds like he's in the fucking clockwork orange.
Um, but I am off often furious. His name was Fred.
I knew it was one of my names. Right. Um, all right, what am I doing here?
Let's, let's, let's read some fucking advertising here.
34 fucking minutes into this podcast and I don't think I'm,
I don't think I'm even remotely a better person. What about you guys? Um,
alright. Oh, it's our friends here. No, wait, let's, let's,
let's stay on this point here. Maybe. Maybe that's what I should,
I'm going to try that today.
I'm going to just try walking around and what I'm gonna do is have my eyebrows
up a little bit. I'm going to do that thing that, uh, people do.
You know where they make their lips disappear,
their mouth looks like it's closed, but their lips disappearing on the car.
I'm just going to do that. Walk around like, Oh yeah,
of course this thing that should take 90 seconds.
Of course now it's going to take six minutes. Yup. Okay.
Take my car over to the dealership to get the a, the brake light done. I mean,
I know that I could change out a break lake, but of course you've uh,
have the screws, they are there inside the car behind a plastic thing.
And I know when I go to take that thing off that they are the head on the screw
is going to be something I've never seen before and requests and requires a
special screwdriver that I could go down or maybe order on Amazon.
Do you know when? Of course they won't just sell me the one,
I'll have to buy the whole set and then I'll be like, well,
I guess I can pay fucking $35 for a new set of screwdrivers and hope I don't get
a ticket over the next few fucking days.
Or I could just drive down to this fucking dealership and just pay 180 bucks for
a fucking like, oh, look at married, get mad again.
Okay,
I'm just going to go down to the dealership and just say, yes,
I have something I could totally repair on my car.
If you guys hadn't put those alien screws in there,
excuse me,
could I have the screwdriver that I need to undo those four screws?
Could I, could I have that please?
And could I then find the corporate guy right as he's getting on his jet who
came up with this idea and could I please just, I don't know,
just sort of stick it into the side of his neck. I think that would be nice.
How does that work? If I say angry shit, but I say it in a pleasant way.
[inaudible]
ma'am.
Is there a reason why you're so not focused as you work this cash register?
Is there a reason why you feel that you above a job that you stink at?
How does that work?
Shouldn't you be so good at this job that I'm actually sitting there thinking to
myself, why are you working here? You're way beyond this.
Why are you standing here reinforcing that you're not even good enough to do
this job because you think you're better than another job.
Is there any way you could open that cash register door and I could grab you by
your ponytail,
shove your head into the drawer and then see how far I could close it with your
head in it. Is there a way I could do that?
Sorry guys, you just don't,
I have to rehearse everything then I'm going to go through today. Oh,
hello staples. Um, no you cannot. You cannot have my phone number. I mean,
I'll give you a phone number and I will give you an alternate phone number. Yes,
I will. None of these will be true. I'll, I'll, I'll give you a,
I'll give you a, a, you know my fake email addresses that I give, it's,
you know it@alaol.com.
You got to have a fake one. You know it@aol.com.
That's my fake one. And that is a reference to willow feral in old school.
Frank the tank when they go on fractal tank, right? He's gone. You know,
um, the fake phone number I give out is a series of area codes followed by the
number of five. They'll be like, what's your, uh,
what's your phone number? It's like a three, two, three, two one,
two eight one eight five. That's what I do.
But they start to look at you after two area coats.
You know when you go like three one oh two, one two. They get that.
You get that little puppy look, that little cock in their head.
And then rather than saying eight, one eight,
cause they're gonna know I go eight one, eight, five.
So I still get it in there. A fake name I go with all the time.
Russell Russell, whenever I just need a first name. What's your name? Hey,
what's your name? Russell. Russell. What can I do for you today? Well, you can,
you can start by not asking me personal questions. All right,
that's what you can do. And you can get some loafers.
Aren't that fit your fucking feet. How about that? All right. That tight shoes.
Um, I'm sorry. I don't know what to tell you. Oh, by the way,
I, uh, you know, I got some video,
my old buddy cleo and um,
she seems happy as hell and this is unprecedented.
This person that I gave my dog to is a dog trainer and um,
at like the fucking dog whisperer level. So, which is what my dog needed.
And he sent me video of something I've never seen before.
My dog came in and wanted to play with another dog,
which my dog never did. My dog tried to kill her, the dogs.
My dog tried to kill another dog when my dog was with the trainer that now has
it a slowly been working with this fucking thing and um,
it was amazing. And the trainer said, you know,
within a week to 10 days they will probably be just like best of friends
sleeping together in the sun.
So that made me feel good cause I think she's actually happier.
Um, and that environment than she was with me, even though, you know,
I miss her to death or what, but that made me feel good. So there you go.
There you go. I'll tell you that fucking dog has had an amazing life,
an amazing life. Like, uh,
literally it should've been over like three different times and it always
survives and its life has gotten progressively better. So, uh,
they made me feel good as much as I, uh, as much as I missed the thing. Um,
that's cool. It's got a Fred and I got nobody.
Whew. Alright. Oh, here we go. Let's read a little advertising you. Oh, zip.
[inaudible]
are you high? You're in. Hey,
do you know where to post your job to find the best candidates posting jobs in
one place? Is it enough to find quality candidates? Ah, you,
you want to find the perfect high or you need to post your job and all is shines
Joan.
And now you can with ziprecruiter.com you can post your job to 100 plus job
sites,
including social media networks like Facebook and fuck it.
Okay.
All with a single click. Find candidates in any city or industry nationwide.
Just post once and watch your qualified candidates roll into ZipRecruiter's.
Easy to use interface. No juggling emails or calls to your office.
Quickly screen candidates, rate them and hire the right person fast.
Find out today. Why Zip?
Okay. [inaudible]
brewed up.com um,
ZipRecruiter has been used by over 1 million businesses and right now my
listeners can post jobs on zipper. Cruder buy for free by going to
ziprecruiter.com/burger that's ziprecruiter.com/burrow one more time. Hey,
drive for free. Go to zip [inaudible]
dot com slash burb oh, give me the Lou Lou crate. Everybody. Hey nerds.
Listen Up. Put Down Your fucking devil dog. Quit licking the sides like a creep.
All right. Be The envy of your friends.
Get your 100% exclusive crates@lukecraig.com slash burr and enter my code bur
bur to save $3 off any new subscription. Wait until I tell you,
oh wait until I tell you about January crate.
It'll take you back to the old school, you know? All right.
Copy points mentioned at least three times a spot.
Yeah.
I don't get like today. Well maybe the,
these ads are so fucking long cause I read everything.
Copy mentioned at least three times as spot.
Mention what?
Why don't you write what the fuck I'm supposed to meet on? You know,
it'd be nice if you guys would just write down what I'm supposed to mention and
then I don't have to do the math and the copy. I would really appreciate that.
Okay, Luke. Great.
Okay.
You're fucking guts. All right. Luke.
Great offers an epic range of pop culture items for less than $20 a month.
What are they giving you a key change? 20 less than $20 a month.
That sounds like a bunch of shit.
If you're more of fanatical fashion east and then try loot where I'll,
here we go. Here's where you start spending your money.
Monthly wearables and accessories with cult classics and your favorite
franchises. If you want to get fancy,
get a bigger box with even bigger loot with Luke crate DX.
This offer expires January 19th at 9:00 PM Pacific.
Get ready for January's old school theme origins. Everybody origins.
Luke [inaudible] has awesome and exclusive items from your old school favorites.
Can you just fucking get to them this January?
You see where it all started and explored the iconic origins with historic items
featuring superman, Captain America,
Mario Batali,
Mario who Super Mario Luigi and the teenage mutant Ninja Turtles,
including as always our monthly tee shirt and pin. Go to Lou,
crate.com/bird and enter my code birth to save $3 off any new subscription
today. I have no fucking idea what any of that is.
I don't know what just happened there. The origins,
like the first
comic book,
Do you need to explore the origins of teenage mutant Ninja Turtles? It's,
it's all on the Internet. Superman.
That goes back to the 30s there was no internet back then.
The Internet came out in the late sixties right when Al Gore was in his fucking
i's dorm room. Right. He was in there with Donald Trump and they are,
they both came up with it.
They should both host a game show called a what I invented de. No,
it's like to tell the truth and you got to guess, right? Just the two of them.
Just sit there talking shit, you know. All right. I'm sorry. Dollar Shave Club.
Everybody. Dollar Shave Club delivers amazing, affordable ranges,
right to your front door. Every fucking months. You can get a great shave,
but raises it only thing you need in the bathroom.
What about all this shower stuff? Oh yeah, kid,
you gotta wash your run to carriage. You know it's an old school thing.
Instead of saying you need to shave, you know those older guys. Hey,
you need to, you need to take a shave. Hey, why don't you take a shave,
take a shave like a shit. What are you saying? They're fucking GRANDPA.
All right. Turns out dollar Shave Club. Thought of that thought of what?
Taking a shave. Oh, buying a oh shower shit. Alright.
They just came out with a new line of shower products.
Shampoo and body wash called the wanderer
where lab, the type of guy who likes to wash his balls.
The fragrances are unlike anything on the market.
There's subtle and actually smell like real natural ingredients.
There are a lot of body washes out there that make you smell like a teenager.
This mint and Cedar Wood Body Wash is amazing and makes you smell incredible.
How is that natural to walk around smelling like ice cream and like you just
chopped some lumber? It makes no fucking sense to me whatsoever.
You know what I mean? I know meant in Cedar would exist, exist in nature.
I don't know. You got to give it a try. Uh,
once you're in the club, you'll see, uh, the products work amazingly.
The surface is world class and you're going to smell like a hummingbird's taint.
There's no longterm commitments, no hidden fees and your cans.
You can cancel whenever you want and best of all they giving you,
oh given away a one month trial of any razor for a dollar with free shipping,
that's not really giveaway. Be Given in a way you're giving it away.
You don't ask people for money after that. It's just a few bucks a month.
Get your $1 trial@dollarshaveclub.com slash bar that's dollar shave
club.com/burr and lastly, but not leastly. Thank fucking God here. Stamps,
stamps.com um,
one great resolution you can make for the [inaudible] the new year.
Maximize every minute and every dollar for your small business.
I know an easy way to do that.
I'm gonna read this like a creepy cold leader trying to get your money and
gradually bring into the fold.
I know an easy way to do that with stamps.com.
Think about how much time you've wasted,
how much time you've wasted going to the post office,
driving there, finding parking,
spending your own money on things that you want to spend it on.
I think it's time he came into my compound and started spending your money on me
because I am truly the son of God.
Not only that, stamps.com is the better way to get postage.
Just use what you already have.
You don't need to go cause you're already there. Your computer and printer, t,
t, I. N what the Fuck? I'm sorry. Just use whatever you have. All right,
you can use your computer, your printer,
and get official US postage for any letter or package.
Then the mailman picks it up with stamps.com everything you would do with the
post office you write from your desk and at a fraction of the cost,
one of those expensive posted meter.
I use stamps.com so whenever I'm sending out my posters,
I'm a fucking Moore and if I can figure it out. So can you, so right now,
sign up for stamps.com and use my code bur bur for this special offer,
four week trial plus $110 bonus offer that includes postage and a digital scale.
All right, don't wait. Go to stamps.com before you do anything else,
you click on the microphone at the top of the home page.
You type in Burr that stamps.com and tuber stamps.com never go to the Goddamn
fucking post office again. All right,
let's do the reeds for this week and then I'll get the fuck it all right.
Sorry. Red The anger one goodwill.
Hey Bill. Bill podcast. Can't wait for F.
F is for family seasoned too. Thank you very much.
Last week on the Thursday podcast, you talked about goodwill.
I worked at goodwill for a little over a year and you wouldn't believe this shit
that was donated there. Oh my God. This fascinates the hell out of me.
I imagine they give you basically everything short of a body.
Um, you are totally right. Uh, they just throw all this shit and trucks,
but they, but instead of throwing shit in the oceans,
yeah, wait a second. But they, instead of throwing shit in the oceans,
put the trucks in warehouses and let them set for at least three to 10 years so
the shit can get a lovely set of molds over them.
When they get loaded, they literally throw this shit on the truck.
Nine times out of 10 braking, whatever you are donating.
No Way. You know what the Shit,
you know what the shit thing is about donating to goodwill?
You can break shit with mold, piss,
shit or anything else disgusting there and they have to take it.
Well then what are they supposed to do with it?
I'd put it on a truck to nine times out of 10 they will take anything but that
one time out of 10 if you bitch and threatened to call corporate and complain,
they will take no matter they'll take it no matter what. Nope.
Somebody's got to do a documentary on goodwill. When I was there,
people would donate trash. They didn't want to pay to get rid of couches,
torn to shit with piss stains all over it.
Mattresses with literal shit on them and a laundry list of low of long gross
shit. Dude, this is like an Expo Zay and I'm taking this all is fact.
I have no idea if this is true or not. They will literally sell anything.
I got to the point that when people would donate things that were really nice,
I would tell them they should keep it or it to someone because it would just be
thrown away.
But of course the mouth breathing assholes that would donate trash that they,
that they have to what,
but of course the maltreating assholes that would donate trash that they have to
take. Dude, you're a bit of a mouth breather here.
You're not speaking in full sentences. Uh,
these people are hoarders that you can't even open their car door without shit
falling all over the fucking place. Fucking discussing.
The grossest thing that I ever saw get sold was either a mattress with shit and
piss stains on it,
or an antique dildo that had white hair all over it.
Ah, ah. Come on. Come on. Come on people. I can't believe this. This, this. I'm,
am I getting trolled here? Is this a millennial? Is he giving me the business?
He says,
I know this is going to sound like I am making myself in this situation.
What I know this is going to sound like I am making myself in this situation.
The good guy is this a voice text.
But I seriously would look at them and be like,
why the fuck are we selling this? This is really wrong. They will respond with,
we have to sell everything to try and make bonus.
The sad thing was we never made bonus.
I got to the point where I wouldn't press shit because it was garbage.
And my last day I felt like grabbing a trash bag from the office,
go around the building, picking up trash, then tying it, tie it up,
slap a dollar on it and write on the bag mystery bag or some shit like that and
see if anybody would buy it. But I didn't do, this is all,
that was all one sentence on my last day.
I felt like grabbing a trash bag from the office, go around the building,
picking up trash, then tie it up,
slap a dollar on it and write on the bag mystery bag or some shit like that and
see if someone would buy it. But I didn't. Oh one sentence.
Thanks bill for the labs and good luck to you and Nia with the new baby. Um,
yeah, I kinda, I kinda get it,
but people just use goodwill cause they want to feel like they're being
environmentally conscious. You know, I'm not throwing this out.
It's going to end up in a landfill or in the ocean and then you just bring it
down there and they just throw it out. Yeah. Well it didn't take a genius.
You come down and there's a giant fucking 18 wheeler empty just parked there
now. Like it's dropping off or picking up shit. It's shit. It's there on,
it's on his legs. There's no a tractor trailer there and you know,
they just come over there like once a day and just drive that thing away.
Where's it going? Alright.
Drama Queen Dad a dear Billy red nose. First off,
I'd like to say thanks for man. Thank you. Thank you. I'm a lady. Oh my God.
I have a female Finn in high school and lately I've been listening to your
podcast whenever I'm stressed out or just looking for something to laugh at.
Okay. Now onto the story.
My father is a middle aged man with bipolar disorder and likes to blame
everything on his mental illnesses. He calls it.
I like that you're already taking them to task here.
He's going to blame everything on his mental illness. Yeah.
That's no reason to not do your dishes. All right. All right. They'll loopy.
He's very dramatic and claims that his bipolar is the reason he hasn't been able
to hold a job lately,
even though he kept the same career for about 10 years and is now working for a
new company by parents are divorced.
So whenever my father can't have us over to visit,
he claims it's because of his illness. Ah, man. That's the greatest.
That there's nothing like a fucking builtin excuse.
That's gonna be great when I have a kid here in a few fucking days, minutes,
weeks, whatever. Um, ah, you know, I'd love to, but my kid, my kid's, uh, yeah,
I can, I got a kid. Um,
I don't want to tell him him that bipolar disorder is not a mental illness
because he, he'd go ape shit on him. Um,
his bipolar, I don't know. I thought anytime your brain was fucked up,
you had a mental illness. I have a mental limbless with my anger. Okay.
Bipolar.
Bipolar. Is it a
okay
disease? Oh, let's see here. Oh,
just give me the fucking answer.
Oh, Jesus.
Oh fuck you. I'm not reading all this shit.
Yeah,
this is the Internet. I don't want to expound it on. Just give me the yes or no.
Is there a yes or no.com? Can you just do that? Just answer a fiasco. Fucking,
it's like, I don't want to know why
is this blah, blah, blah, yes or no. And then you have your answers.
So then when you go to the bar and somebody says something you like, no,
it is our, yes, it is Yarra. It is.
Do you know that bipolar disorder develops during a person's late teens or early
adult years? Do you know? I didn't ask that question.
Never trust a fucking doctor with a goatee.
Yeah.
Where the fuck is it? A, you know. Oh my God. Jesus Christ.
Look at these fucking eggheads here. I'll get a nice full heads of hair though.
I've got to give them that. All right. Anyways, um,
I don't want to tell them bipolar disorder is not a mental illness because he'll
go ape shit on me for some reason.
He seems to enjoy making me my sister feel like shit and makes mountains out of
molehills whenever we correct him or stand up for ourselves when he bullies us.
Yeah. I don't take any shift. He sounds like an asshole.
What's even worse about this is that his bullying always works.
He's very manipulative and I'm scared to see him because of the things he said
and done to me in the past. Every time I'm,
I'm informed I'll have to spend the weekend with him. Um,
I nearly piss myself with anxiety. My question to you is,
how the fuck do you deal with someone like this?
I know my dad is ridiculous and uses underhanded tactics,
tactics to make me feel like shit,
but for some reason I'm not able to just get over it.
None of my friends seem to relate to being so terrified of one person.
Like I am of my father and I'd like to hear your take on things.
Thanks for reading this and go fuck yourself. Um,
yeah.
All right. How would I get past it? Well, this is the hardest thing to do.
You have to stop giving a shit about the guy to a certain level at some point.
You know, when you, if you have a parent like this,
you have to look at them and remove mentally that they're a relative and you
have to just say to yourself, like, if this person was a complete stranger,
would I be friends with this person? Would I interact with this person?
Would I waste another minute, my fucking life dealing with this person?
You know? And when you got to ask those questions, usually it's like,
absolutely not. This would have been a fucking one and done situation.
But the thing is, is is your dad, she can't write them off,
but you have to kind of,
that's the toughest thing when you've got to write off a parent but still
interact with them. You just gotta be like, I don't know.
You kind of have to find the humor in it. I think that's a tough one. Um,
especially at your age.
Um,
I dunno, I would just,
I don't know that I would probably could do some passive aggressive shit where I
would just say grow. Yeah. Is that how it is? Okay, I'll get right on that.
You know, Shit like that. I don't know what to tell you. I would just basically,
um,
okay.
I would still like, what is he going to do other than get mad? He does.
It doesn't sound like he hits you or anything.
So he just mad and he flips out or whatever and just I stop.
Who gives a fuck? That's what he's going to do.
The guy's out of his fucking mind, right? Maybe he's got bipolar,
maybe it doesn't. Maybe it's a disease. Maybe it isn't all, you know, they just,
Oh man, this is tough. This is, it's fun. This is a fucking rough one.
Cause it's your dad and the last thing you want to do is then go out in the
world and start dating somebody who then treats you like ditch that,
the exact fucking thing you don't want.
And then you end up with that and then you have that same nervousness in a
fucking relationship. That's all I can say. You know what you got to do?
You're not going to be able to fix this guy.
You gotta deal with them because he is your dad. Um,
but the big thing that you could do is in your life is you create a life that
does not involve this. All right?
You need to go out and go marry a fucking suit,
right?
And then your fucking house is great and it's peaceful and it's what you want.
And then every once in a while this fucking tornado tornado blows through and
you deal with it and then it leaves and then you go back to your peaceful life.
Um, that's all you can do. You really, as a kid,
you really can't do anything about your parents. You can't pick them.
You just get the ones that you get. But, uh,
the thing that you can do is create a life that does not involve that.
And then you don't do that shit to your kids. And then you break the cycle,
then that's it. You know? But the weird fucking thing is, is that your,
your decks still always going to be in your life, you know,
so that lunatic will then be around your kids and it's just, it's a,
it's a motherfucker he really is,
but unfortunately they for the most part die before we do. And then, you know,
you don't have to deal with them anymore.
So I guess try to find the fucking humor in it
while you're dealing with it and then think of how exciting your life is going
to be. Um, by not having that in it. You know,
you might want to just Skype with them for awhile,
get yourself in a situation and be like, what? I think the screen froze hello.
And you just click. Um, but that's really a,
that's disappointing to hear that an adult would manipulate a teenager,
forget about his own fucking daughter. That's sucked. So I don't try that,
but just know that you can go out in the world and have any life that you want
to have, uh, simply by, you know, you know,
he's showing you what you don't want. All right. There you go. Oh man,
that's brutal.
You fuck you fuck up so bad as a parent that your daughter goes out going,
I want to marry a man who is the exact opposite of my own dad. Poof.
That's game set. Match. You fucked up as a father. All right. Sisters,
girlfriend, dear bill, the red bitch birth. Uh,
my twin sister is a lesbian and she's dating the lady who was bisexual.
She was bisexual. And then what?
Okay.
Then what became totally homosexual and went back to heterosexuality or is she
asexual? At first we didn't, we weren't close or anything,
but we did get along with your twin sister, not the bisexual woman. Right.
Then about a year ago, we ran into each other at a club in the and Oh,
I know you're talking about the bisexuality.
My sister is a lesbian and she was dating a lady who was bisexual first.
We weren't close or anything but,
but we got along and I'm assuming you're talking about the bisexual lady then
about a year ago we ran into each other and at downtown club, uh, we,
we had a few drought. Jesus, we have a few drinks.
Just start talking about random stuff. Uh, she came back,
she's going to try to fucking,
she can try to finger bang the whole family here until a friend of mine invited
us to a party at some guy's house. We went and had a lot more to drink.
And then one thing led to another.
W what does anything good ever come after? And then, you know,
one thing led to another. That's when you're fast forwarding through some,
a piece of shit thing you did or something you're embarrassed of, hey, you know,
one thing led to another. No one ever talks about fucking a, hey,
how did you hit that? When that winning game shot? Well,
they inbounded the ball and now one thing led to another and uh, you know,
I hit the, I hit the shot to win the championship.
You will tell every fucking detail I was riding down the court with every step.
I can feel my IP. I knew somebody had to step up, let me do this.
I'm always going to be me. Right? That's how you tell it when you fucking,
when you did some good shit, you did some bad shit. Yeah.
One thing led to another and uh,
the guy was on the ground and he wasn't breathing.
So I don't know what happened. Okay. One thing led to another.
We ended up having sex. The next day we came,
we came to and both felt horrible about what happened.
You both came to, I just pictured that fucking, you know,
take my picture, smack my bitch up.
Remember that Madonna was in the background going on.
[inaudible] she was saying like the fucking opening to star Trek. Um,
the next day we came to in both felt horribly about what happened.
She then told my sister that she slept with a man,
but didn't tell her it was me. Oh, wait, you're a guy.
I thought this was a lady.
Oh, okay. Okay. I bisexual. I don't know. All right. Wait a minute.
Wait a minute. All right. Your twin sister is a lesbian.
She's dating the ladies bisexual, Yada, Yada.
At first you weren't close or anything, but we got along okay.
And then you ran into her and you fucked,
you fucked your fucking sisters
girlfriend.
No wonder you went with one thing led to another.
Then we came to like, you were both drugged. Ah,
these are classic. You feel horrible about this sir,
or you don't and uh, but you want to get away with it.
So you're blowing through the details. While this is very,
this is very underwritten for what the fuck is just gone down here.
Jesus Christ. Uh,
she then told my sister that she slept with a man but didn't tell her it was me
too. This chick is a psycho, uh,
for the past year I've been torn up about it.
I need your unbiased style of advice.
Should I tell my sister that was me or not? Thanks. Ps, come to blah,
blah, blah. I would love to see you again. Um, dude, no, don't say a few.
Die with that.
Secret that with that secret hope that woman fades away and then if shit ever
comes back around,
she said it was you and just be like it was the fire.
What time you wake up with Drake? Oh, one thing led to another.
I wouldn't say a fucking word.
Okay.
Don't say a fucking word. Okay.
The fly in the ointment here is his bisexual lady. Okay.
She's jumping all over the fence. She's fucking sister.
She's fucking brothers and she's fucking white people. No kidding.
She's fucking two people that she's, she's the fly in the fucking ointment.
Okay. She said this shit. Um, I don't know why she's doing that. This is like,
this is, she's like Glenn Close, um, in fatal attraction.
If she fucked both Michael Douglas in the Hottie was married to and the rabbit,
okay. She's fuck this lady. Just, you know, you just sit tight.
Okay. This is like in a sub and you cut the engines and you're just hoping that
they're not going to start dropping deaf charges.
You just hope you get through it sometimes in life. You just shut the fuck up.
I, this was one, I wouldn't say anything. Okay.
Okay.
And if she brings it up, yeah, you slept with her. I would just, I mean,
what are you going to do? This is the thing, you just,
this lady's out of her fucking mind.
There's no way your sister's going to end up with her, okay?
There is no way she's going to end up with her. All right?
This woman's out of her fucking mind. So she's eventually going to fade away.
All you have to do is just hope that when it comes time for the breakup,
that the crazy bitch is breaking up with your sister.
Because if your sister goes to break up with her in that highly emotional
moment, she might drop the ball, okay?
And then you would just, you just gotta play it. Like she said, what
now had never had. She's just like, well, you just breaking up that she said,
that's why she was saying it because you broke and that she walks to the room.
You're like, oh, all right. I did it
because one thing led to another.
Alright, call my parents down a Billy blue lungs.
I don't know what that means.
I'm 24 years old and I'm dating a woman that is 34 years old. Uh, all right.
See you fucking in all the lady. You're not dating. Come on. What do you do?
Oh wait,
what are you going to have your first kid with her when she's like 96 we've been
dating for close to three years now and I couldn't be happier.
We recently bought a house. So Gigi, you're 24.
You're dating a 34 year old and you bought a house with her recently bought a
house. I would be nervous if this was flipped in.
The guy was 34 and it was a 24 year old. He's still a wild horse man.
You got to run out in the range. Um,
we recently bought a house and finally came time to put down the down payment on
the house and all that extra stuff. I'm going to be honest,
that ego issues on the down payment,
she knows my financial status and she was cool with it,
but I just wanted to provide more because she does so much for me.
So I dropped my car insurance without her knowing to give her the extra money,
even though she said I didn't need to. I felt like,
what sort of man would I be if I didn't contribute my part? So my luck has it.
I got into a car accident literally two weeks after I dropped my car insurance.
I'm between a rock and a hard place. Now we want to start a family,
but I'm guessing my license would be suspended for a year.
A lot of burden will be put upon her now that I'm,
I'm assuming my license will be suspended for some time. Bill, any,
if you could do me a solid on this one, that would be great. Ps,
longtime listener, first time, email. Ah, Geez. What are you,
what are you asking me? Like, yeah, you're fucked. You are fucked.
I agree with that. Um,
well I um, in life sometimes you learn a hard lesson, sir,
and you learn in right now. I'm sorry, I don't know what to tell you. You
with this woman, I mean, the solution you,
what you learned is the solution is not doing what you did.
You don't expose yourself to that type of a liability.
Um,
okay.
You didn't really ask me a question. Uh,
all right. So you love this person. You, you want to start a family,
that's all good and you fucked up. Uh, I would, I guess if you haven't told her,
I would come clean. Tell her what you did, why you did it.
Say you're sorry. And uh,
and I don't what you, what's your, you're 24 and you want to be able to provide,
she's 34 and you're going to get married and you're going to start a family.
I don't know how you'd be able to provide, you've got to get your career going.
I would think so.
That would be my biggest concern once I find out what the judgement against me
is going to be. But uh, here's the deal dude.
She's 34 year 24. She should be making more money than you.
She should have more money than you. Her life should be further down there,
you know, uh, you can't try to catch up to a 34 year old. Alright.
Cause the only way for you to do it is to do what you just did.
And you ended up fucking yourself over. And in the long run,
you fuck her over too. So, um,
you have to respect the fact that you're the age you're at, you're at. And uh,
I would try to figure out what the fuck I wanted to do with my life and I would
try to get that career going and I would hope that there would be a bus close by
that I can take to get me to that because you're,
I think you're going to get fucked here. Sorry to say that. But um, yeah,
my advice would be to stop trying to measure up to a 34 year old,
just be 24. All right. I hope that helped you out. Um,
but that's all I got. Sorry. Okay. Alright. That's the podcast for this week.
If you'd like to donate to the podcast,
you can always do that anytime you shop on Amazon. Well, how do I do that, bill?
Well,
you just go to [inaudible] dot com you click on the podcast page and there's an
Amazon link you click on that takes you right to Amazon you,
it doesn't cost you any extra money.
I get credit for driving traffic to that site, Yada, Yada, Yada.
Pulled to do the doodle, whatever, whatever the fuck you want to say them.
All right. And they give me a little bit of money. All right. That's it.
That's it man. Go fuck yourselves. And I'll check in on you on a, on Thursday.
Congratulations to USC. Congratulations to Clemson, Alabama.
[inaudible] we're going to see who's going to fucking win that one.
And a NFL playoffs. Playoffs are coming.
Bruins had a nice two game win streak over the sabers and then we fucking lost
yesterday. I missed that game. Got fucking smoked three to nothing.
But what do we play? Played fucking the Carolina Hurricanes. Um,
that's it. Hey everybody, the holidays are over to brand new fucking year. Uh,
don't deal with bipolar people. All right? If you've got to make a left,
get over towards the double line. Uh, don't liquidate your fucking insurance.
So, uh, you can try to fucking
bang a 40 year old and uh,
I think that's it. Yeah.
And if you bang your a lesbian sister's girlfriend,
keep your fucking mouth shut. Alright. Talk to you on Thursday.